hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that just ended uh from round
five of the uh tata still chess
tournament 2022. it's niels grandelius
with the white pieces against magnus
carlsen now carlson has uh well he's
having a fine tournament so far it's not
excellent and he's not uh pushing
towards that 2900 goal uh but it's uh
still okay he's still kind of tying for
first maybe
getting in second third so he he is
somewhat in the lead whereas grandelus
lost already three games and he drew one
so it would be very nice to get uh
anything but a loss here with the white
pieces against magnus it's a really
crazy game uh
both players uh will have their chances
as you'll see so let's check it out so
granddale's with the white pieces opens
with e4
we have c5 magnus goes for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 we have knight to
c6 and of course d4 opening up the the
sicilian we have captures captures and
now e6 uh that time man of variation of
the sicilian with knight to c3 and now
queen to c7 the bastrop line uh and um
uh grendel has already had this position
in this exact same tournament against
rihanna rapport
where he played g4 right away it's a
very sharp line and the magnus as he's
playing this of course he's very well
prepared for this so granddale throws in
a nice bishop to e3 and only now after
a6 he goes for this g4 move yeah now you
usually you play some like queen to d2
or bishop to d3 just continue
development but he really likes his g4
line against this setup so here
magnus plays knight captures on d4 and
it's um with the idea that okay you just
played g4 you've opened up this diagonal
uh so we want to play b5 and put a
bishop on b7 we're definitely doing this
and
magnus could do it the way he did it for
example with knight captures on d4 or
you could play b5 right away but now for
example knight captures queen captures
and then we're gonna put a bishop on b7
at some point but um
not just not right away so it's a matter
of preference so so to say so here
magnus played knight captures on d4 we
have queen captures now he develops um
grendel uses queen uh without any effort
uh
from him and only now b5 uh we have
queen side castles and bishop to b7 now
gaining control of this diagonal and now
the position has been reached before and
there are a couple of very nice games
for example ananda beat fun forest here
with with king to b1 also yannipon she
drew against caruana with king to b1 so
king b won a popular move here but f3 is
actually the engine's favorite move so
this is what grandillus plays uh saying
that he knows uh his stuff very very
well
uh magnus plays rook to c8 now the
knight cannot move if the knight moves
we're gonna play queen captures on c2
with checkmate so queen back to d2 now
the knight can move and the b4 is no
longer a threat well it's a kind of is
but uh and not another deadly one so
here yeah we have bishop to b4 we have
to continue development
and now comes bishop to d4 defending
here and attacking on g7 and it seems
like you could win the game on the spot
with e5 because where is the bishop
going uh the problem is bishop can
capture on e5 and after the queen
captures we can play queen captures on
the seven king of fate and queen
captures on b7 and uh white is just
winning this you don't even have
something like rook captures on c3 maybe
because rook to d8 with check and after
the queen goes back we simply capture it
captures and i'll be captures on c3 uh
anneals would be very much winning here
so magnus of course prepares the e5 he
plays f6 first and now we have g5 going
after this uh f6 pawn you really want to
open up this this diagonal
and the position is still not a new one
atari versus
in 2021 uh bishop to d6 was played and
toddy won that game very nicely
but the bishop to d6 isn't optimal here
magnus plays h6 and this is now also the
strongest move recommended by the engine
and it is now as a move 13
that we have a completely new game so
this is now unexplored territory
uh let's see how how niels deals with
this he plays g captures on h6
and okay black has to react to this you
still don't have time for e5 magnus
plays knight captures on h6 and now we
have a3 and a3 is a move that says uh
well a lot but also uh asks a lot of
questions so here he he's basically
saying that you can capture on a3 remove
the defender of the knight and c3 and
the dead this is fine for white uh so
magnus says all right let's see what you
got bishop captures on a3 b captures an
a3 and now e5 uh well either trapping
the bishop or the bishop moves and then
we win back our piece uh but now niels
plays knight captures on b5 he attacks
the queen here so a captures on b5 and
now he just moves the bishop bishop back
to b2
and now comes the
really fun part here magnus immediately
strikes in the center with the d5 but
before
i show you what happened in the game we
have to discuss one line
because here
people were asking questions they were
they were asking whether
magnus is just playing very creative
chess whether he just sacrificed upon
and now he's going to sacrifice another
one or even more uh or or he just mixed
up lines so which is it and now i'm
going to show you one position that
starts with knight to f7 it's similar to
what happened in the game uh but
different uh for one a very specific
reason and after white makes a move for
example h4 now we play d5 and now let's
say okay bishop captures on b5 we offer
this pawn with check even in the line
that was actually played king to f8
queen to b4 with check king the g8 and
now this queen to b3 move uh does
doesn't really do anything but in the
actual game it does a lot because now
the knight is on f7 and you are not
pinned here the pawn can move you can
play d4 this is perfectly fine for black
so now white would have to look for
something else so instead of this uh
knight back to f7 magnus went for d5
right away and this is a very very bold
move because it doesn't only give up the
b pawn it also gives up the d pawn if
white is brave enough to capture it so
here we have bishop captures and b5 with
check king to f8 and now uh the the line
that we've discussed uh niels doesn't go
for it niels played bishop to a4 here uh
he senses that there could be some uh
trouble here on the c21 so bishop to a4
guarding this uh definitely makes sense
but we also have to show the forcing
queen to be for check look at this
bishop covers this diagonal queen covers
this diagonal you're going to play king
to g8 and now we play queen b3 and now
the pawn isn't going anywhere there
isn't this uh
d4 move for black because the knight is
not on f7 and after you make a move
let's say knight to f7 now we play e
captures on d5 and now we've won not one
but two pawns and now for example after
knight to d6 you get this position uh
where okay black has a lot of counter
play for two pawns but with uh with
even a decent play white should not have
any any problem here
so it's uh
really interesting what magnus had in
mind uh had uh grendelus actually went
for this because you have immense
pressure over the c file uh okay white
has the bishop pair but what is the
bishop para even doing the dark square
bishop doing nothing light square bishop
not doing all that much with with the d5
pawn here blockaded by the knight uh it
would be a very very interesting to see
what would happen here the rook can
easily join the game with rook to h4
then being shifted somewhere to the
queen side for the moment there aren't
that many squares but
obviously obviously magnus had something
in my mind for this
but okay yeah it did not happen bishop
to a4 was played and now magnus very
very happily uh uh advances this pawn
all the way to d4 we have bishop to b3
also very nice because it cuts the king
off from escaping anywhere now even
ideas like bishop to a for this bishop
coming to a3 could be possible forcing
the king back into the center of the
board so knight to f7 and now we have a
queen to be for check
we have king the g8 now
it looks like uh you don't have all that
much to do here but this is actually
perfectly fine for black we rook to d2
uh not only defending the c2 pawn one
more time but also you can double up
rooks on the g file and put some
pressure along the
along the g file so bishop to a6 uh now
again gaining more control over the d3
square so at some point the d3 might
also be a terrible threat uh and now we
have f4 other than f4 you don't really
have a good move here because the
position is so uh so uh
fragile
we have rook the b8 attacking the queen
here queen to a4 and now bishop to b5
attacking the queen queen to b4 now
offering
magnus a lot of nasty discoveries but
for the moment there really isn't a good
one we have bishop to a6 again opening
up an attack queen a4 bishop b5 queen to
b4 granddale who says i'm very very
happy with the draw here
are you happy with the draw uh and here
magnus played rook to h3 a rook to h3
can be played but also bishop to e2 is
very nice
the reason bishop to e2 is very nice is
after queen to a4 now we play rook to h3
and now we have this uh well a very cool
position where you're you're threatening
to capture the bishop here the pawn is
pinned so you're not going to be able to
capture back so we'd see something like
captures king captures rook captures on
e2 is not a possibility this bishop is
just very well placed here so you'd have
to go for something like f captures on
e5 first uh point being that if rook
captures rook h to b3 and again white
will not be able to survive this this is
just an overwhelming attack so very
extremely complicated stuff so okay
magnus went for rook to h3 right away we
have f captures on e5 f captures and now
rook the g1
rook to f2 also
a very nice idea but in the game rook
the g1 was played and now
magnus has to find a very very nice move
but it's not easy to find it yeah it's a
really tricky position and uh
it's hard to
hard to spot such a movie if you if you
if you're not sure exactly what you're
looking for but just for fun feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the absolute best move for for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's bishop
to a6 i moved it really fast uh you know
impress you so i hope you guys were
impressed but it was not played in the
game so congratulations to everyone who
found such a strong move uh and i will
show you why it's such a strong move uh
well point is uh your queen is attacked
so what do you do uh you can't really
move the queen because then we captured
the bishop so we have to capture the
knight on f7 with check first bishop
captures on f7 and now what do you play
here yeah well you play king to h8 you
don't play king captures on f7 if you
play king captures and f7 then there's
this tricky rook deep the g2 and then
well you don't care about your queen
being attacked because you're
threatening this pawn and uh after the
king moves you're gonna pick up the
queen and c7 so the point is after
bishop captures an f7 uh we ignore the
bishop we play king to h8 and this is
the star move that will not be possible
uh in the actual game uh because now you
don't really have all that much for
example rook to g3 uh attacking the rook
and now what can black play well black
actually has to go back with rook to h6
point is that
if you go for for the queen here rook
captures an h3 is checkmate bishop
covers g6 and the g8 and it doesn't even
matter if you capture on g3 we play h
captures on g3 and the magnus would
again be lost doesn't matter what you
play rook to h2 will be checkmate even
if g5
and this is the craziest hypothetical
lines a line ever uh if g5 then queen
captures on d4
i mean
what what brutality threatening queen
captures an e5 along with rook to h2 and
if of course the queen is captured we
just capture on the four king h7 and not
rook to h2 with checkmate uh incredible
incredible bishop slicing here regarding
this
just insane
so that's what would happen here after
rook to g3 so magnus would have to go
rogue back to h6 and okay this is
playing the absolute best moves uh now
we bring the bishop back bishop to d5
and only now we have a rook capture sun
before grabbing the queen a captures on
b4 and we would get this position where
magnus would have a bishop queen and the
rook against two rooks and the bishop
pair so
all in all it should be winning for
black uh so that that's uh that's what
was in the position but after rook to g1
magnus doesn't play bishop to a6 magnus
plays bishop to e2 and it's almost
identical but not in the sense that uh
the the bishop on e2 is hanging and
magnus knows that the bishop on e2 is
hanging and of course the bishop cannot
be captured except in the line that
we've just shown
that's winning for black that's the
problem because now okay bishop captures
an f7 was played but uh now magnus
doesn't have king to chad which was
winning in the other line because after
came to h8 now we just give up the queen
for the rook and after queen captures we
even pick up the bishop here and now
white has too much material uh for the
queen two rooks and the bishops pair
against the rook and the queen of course
this would be completely winning to give
you an example let's say rook f3 we go
after the bishop bishop just goes back
to b3 and even if a move like d3 to try
and weaken uh white's position here uh
we're just gonna play rook to g2 attack
g7 we don't care about anything here d
captures on c2 bishop captures it's uh
all white from here
so incredible stuff after bishop
captures an f7 the king h8 that was
working if the bishop was on a6 no
longer works because the bishop is on
pre here on e2 so king captures on f7
has to be played now comes queen to a4
now neil sidesteps the attack we have
queen to b7
attacking the bishop here
and now niels just repeats queen to b4
queen to c7 queen to a4 and now okay the
bishop has to move the bishop is
attacked bishop back to b5 also bishop
to c4 is possible but the position is
too crazy to analyze every move in depth
we have queen back to b4 or rather we
don't have queen back to b4 uh queen
back to b4 would be excellent for magnus
because then uh rook to f3
and now after rook d to g2 going after
the pawn here we can trade off a pair of
rooks captures captures and now of
course it's much much better if rook f
to check king g8 uh what do you play
here if you play rook captures here then
we just play rook captures on b4 so you
have to react to the to the queen being
attacked so queen to d2 something uh and
okay we continue playing this we move
the bishop bishop to h3 bishop can come
to e6 and black will just uh be better
here his position is just better
uh so instead after bishop to b5 rook d
the g2 was played this is the only move
for niels and he spotted it we're
already at move 35 and both players are
extremely low on the clock they're like
five minutes each
uh so this is the only move that uh
continues the game for niels going after
that g7 pawn so magnus goes back rook to
h7 defending this now it's two minutes
for niels uh one minute for magnus and
now comes queen to b3 with check bishop
to c4 now opening a discovery here queen
to g3 a very strong going for queen to
g6 and now queen to b6 magnus now
attacks b2 but also guards the g6 square
and niels goes for the queen trade so
queen g6 check queen captures rook
captures and now rook to c8 threatening
a very nasty move uh because um
well
they still need to make one more move to
reach time control and the problem for
niels is that he has to play king to b1
but he has only a few seconds on the
clock and he needs one more move to
reach mu 40 and reach time control he
plays rook six the g5 goes after the e5
pawn and now okay he reached down
control but now he allowed magnus bishop
to d3 and now he puts pressure on the c2
pawn and again uh from uh from a
completely equal position now you are
again in trouble uh and what do you play
here rook to f5 check is what niels
played a a very interesting idea but
also uh hard for a human to spot is c3
and after pawn captures bishop back to
a1
looks uh weird but you know it it works
bishop captures an e4 rook captures an
e5 uh all in all it's uh it's a it's a
dead draw so after bishop d3 rook f5
check was played with king to g8 and now
rook to f2 this is how he goes back to
defend the c2 pawn and now magnus goes
rook to h6
rook to h6 uh preparing to shift the
rook over to the attack but also
preventing this silly idea of c3 okay
now c3 is no longer needed uh rook to d1
now attacking the bishop and now magnus
plays bishop captures on e4 and although
this seems like a move you really want
to play you actually don't you actually
want to just move the bishop bishop to
b5 uh bring the other rook into the
attack play bishop to a4 and try to
force white to play c3 at some point
maybe keeping the tension but after
bishop captures an e4 it's uh uh well
it's much much easier for niels to play
this rook the e1 was played attacking
the bishop rook to h4 defending and now
we have a4
advancing the pass pawn
rook the c5 now guarding the
the a5 square but also this allows niels
to go for for the well basically for the
instant draw
and that is bishop to a3 bishop to a3
this is beautiful beautifully spotted by
niels bishop the a3 attacks the rook so
the rook has to move you're going to go
to e7 force this rook away from the
defense of the bishop or rather bishop
rook to g4 will be played and then h3
will force the rook away from the
defense of the bishop on e4 very nicely
done so bishop to a3 and now okay you
could go uh rook to rook to c7 to keep
an eye on e7 square but then just bishop
here goes after this pawn so you have to
give up something so rook back to c8 was
played now comes bishop to e7 attacking
the rook here rook to g4 and h3 and now
all of the squares are covered so magnus
has to trade rooks here so here rook g2
uh saying that uh okay you if you
capture the bishop i capture your rook
so you have to trade rooks so rook
captures bishop captures and now finally
rook captures on e5 we have d3 by magnus
now threatening to win this pawn but not
bishop to c5 blocking the rook's attack
towards the c2 pawn so rook to a8 now
magnus shifts the attention over to the
a4 pawn and now c captures on d3 we have
rook captures on a4 king to d2 and now
bishop captures an a3 we have rook to e4
uh offering a trade of rooks but also he
was in this position on move 54
that niels and magnus agree to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
completely equal material bishops are of
opposite colors so you really don't have
anything to look for here so there are
two big questions uh here uh would
magnus win if he found that bishop a6
idea instead of going for bishop to e2
and what would happen if niels actually
accepted carlson's challenge and the
wind for the
uh for the uh
idea that we've discussed after this was
captured not bishop to a4 here but just
going for it with queen to be for check
king g8 and now queen to b3 well what
would happen here knight of 70 captures
on d5 it's a it's an incredible position
for white uh would he be able to
get something here or or would
or or is this something that magnus
actually prepared and was ready to play
this even though the engine gives it
like a minus two for uh for white or
rather minus two in black's favor so
this is another question and did magnus
just blunder his preparation also a fair
question because in that um
uh moment where d5 was played is is
knight to f7 uh uh a move you play first
or did magnus willingly play this and he
knew this and he just wanted to create a
completely crazy line much like much
like for example a towel would uh it
doesn't seem to be the case and very
unlikely because that's not really how
you uh well go forward your goal uh of
reaching 2900 in classical uh but uh you
know anything is possible i guess if if
he mentioned this anywhere or there was
an interview or something do show in the
comments i would be very interesting
very interested in knowing this uh uh
that's the first game of round five that
was shown uh hope you guys uh enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank francis leslie
knope uh matthew waldes mohan churalandi
uh and malaki uh heaven for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
tata steel
until it finishes uh thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day